well the big news coming from tampa was
that uh commissioner roger goodell
gave his pre-super bowl news conference
kind of an annual thing and today he did
it
before the super bowl sports director
chris matthews live in studio
joining us with what he had to tell the
world yeah really it's kind of always
interesting to hear what he has to say
in the sports world nfl football is the
king so it's interesting
to hear what's going on in the league
now if the owners are the emperors then
today we heard from the king
king roger lays out some plans his voice
and what
really he's pleased with a lot of fans
also there was no cancelled games if you
can believe that in the league they made
it to the super bowl
we just kind of want to go through this
was
an extraordinary collective effort
there's so many people
that had to work together to get this
done
there were doubters obviously there were
people that didn't believe we could do
it
obviously we had a lot of unknowns
ourselves
but we believed that staying on schedule
and working towards trying to get 256
games done
as we sort of say shorthand avoid the
asterisk
that's what they did after the
commissioner spoke the halftime
entertainment always gets a few minutes
the weekend honored to be sunday's
halftime entertainment
we kind of built the stage within the
stadium
and uh we're also using the field as
well but we wanted to kind of do
something that we've never done before
and um yeah so we built we built the
stage in the stadium but i'm not going
to tell you anything else
because you'd have to watch on sunday
oh how about that tease denise coming up
at six o'clock we'll have much more in
the game itself
super bowl spelling bee how can you play
super bowl bingo it's going to be a lot
of fun just by watching you can win some
money